[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le canal football club alors marie
c'est très simple un vous travaillez sur
le canal football club
on va faire le canard football quels
jeux vous posez des questions concernant
le football
sachez qu'à chaque fois que vous
donnerez une bonne réponse il se passera
rien si vous donnez une mauvaise réponse
julien courbet est aux cages en canard
et il y à un joueur 1 du red star
vraiment donc c'est un professionnel
tuvalu yannick shincho arrive à lui
atteint des tirs dans la gueule voici la
première qui est une amère d'ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelques stars du monde du foot se cache
derrière ce slip trois propositions au
dévié giroud david beckham ou jean
michel maire elles ont bien géré
oliviero folie légion banale avec un
brésilien fans de foot et de l'équipe de
france a donné un prénom assez original
à son fils
écoutez bien chez vous quel est ce
prénom zizou ribéry junior ou zinedine
yazid zidane thierry henry barthez élite
felipe silva santos alors je le sais
c'est quoi mais je vais dire exprès la
réponse sera pour voir la vérité si vous
vous dites la dernière réponse zinedine
zidane zinedine yazid a pas ce que vous
pensez que c'est une mauvaise réponse
non c'est la bonne réponse je pense
c'est la bonne réponse ziad attention
combien y at-il de places assises dans
le stade maracana de rio 78 1838 76 1784
ou quatre de plus que dans le public des
chiffres et des lettres
la troisième réponse la troisième
réponse alors vous alors mais vraiment
je suis dit en couple sont prennent pas
là juste pour voir
juste pour dire comme ça et des milliers
[Applaudissements]
ali bongo
et irma laissez moi je vais y aller
[Applaudissements]
mélanie balles et il a retiré d'accra
lors d'un match de foot en attaque at il
le droit de prendre le ballon à la main
oui non ça dépend de son signe
astrologique non banon et bien sûr qu'il
a droit s'il fait une touche
ah oui bah oui c'est vrai il tirait sur
converse
[Applaudissements]
les trajets relais
il n'y a pas de questions orales et si
j'avais des calanques a vendu bien
revenez revenez mon julia gillard
reviens et je voudrais remercier
vraiment yannick qui est avec nous deux
joueurs du red star merci dany
[Musique]